one more time Springs way better at it
welcome to the line the scenes for poor
trick shots I put them through the
digital text breakdown performance trick
shots about time we did one of these so
let me tell you guys a little about the
inspiration behind this all the
challenges we have to do in turn putting
it together and all the crazy math that
ran into dude in his head make all the
basketball trajectories look accurate it
wasn't in my head it was on paper this
was one of the most challenging videos
I've ever had to like conceptualize
because there are so many aspects that
go into making a portal like what is a
perspective if you're to look through
this portal it's like okay if you attach
a camera and to a rod to the portal and
flip that portal to the other portal
that would be where the camera would be
and you have to like think about hey
we're with the camera B to get a plate
to put on the other set yeah anyway yeah
we actually use the drone the DJI
inspire to get a lot of the plates
because the poor will be my up on like
the ceiling or underside of the highway
and so we need to get perspective from
there looking down you know me and Sam
doing our thing it's like how do we get
at 40-foot ladder hmm well we have a
drone that's pretty stable up in the air
excuse that just point the camera down
so we went on a street we couldn't fly
underneath the overpass because the
bridge blocked all the GPS data to the
drone so I was flying all over couldn't
keep it steady so we just filmed on
another Street and kind of Compton in to
make it look like that Street stabilized
it just a tad bit you don't need to see
why so much the shots elevate and
complexity as I go on one of my
favorites is probably where Sam throws
the basketball to himself runs through a
portal with the camera following him and
then proceeds to catch the basketball
and make the shot wait a green screen
with a hole cut out of it where the
portal would be and some tracking
markers and we just knows already in our
second location so we jumped through
that caught the basketball and made the
shot basically all we did is track in
the pillar holding up the highway in the
ground so in the background there and
all Explorer real because it's just a
picture that's on screen for a moment
it's a picture that sliced up into
different spots like there's a
background footer there's the pillar
there's a little small pillars in front
so from the same photo but separated in
three-dimensional space so that when the
camera
through it they all move at different
speeds and can it look like it's an
actual real pester yeah every was saying
like there's one effect we haven't seen
in portal videos that's taking the
camera through a portal so we had to do
it
so part of what sells a lot of these
shots is the fact that there is motion
involved the camera is actually moving
through these scenes and to do that we
have two motion track the entire shot
what's called match moving and to do
that we used a program called a zoo to
3d track all these shots so all the
elements in the scene are actually in
their actual spot as if they are in the
video in real life so for simplicity's
take a couple of these shots the
beginning of them were actually filmed
on a tripod and that was just so that we
can get the entire shot all in one frame
and then we can actually move the camera
on the second half of the shot and track
the tripod part of the effect into the
motion shot and it all blends together
really nicely in my opinion the most
crucial part of recreating a real life
boil effect is showing what you would
actually see on the other side of those
portals for example if I also take the
basketball hoop plate from the drone and
actually attach it to where the portal
is you would see instantly that it is
not right so what you do is you film
these other plates on a tripod or
stabilize it somehow he didn't use a
still frame from that perspective that's
why in After Effects you position it so
that it's actually way behind the pillar
and only visible through that portal
using what's called a track map and so
that way when the camera is actually
moving through the scene you get the
proper parallax of the background that
you would actually get if here to be
looking at the background through a
portal now in the last shot we set up an
infinite loop and I'm flying that
infinite loop I took my jacket off
because after that there's a CG double
that was flying out the portal and slam
dunks and do the cloth simulations for
the jacket well cool I would've taken a
lot of times so that's why I tur much
literally the entire reason why he co
took his jacket off was because we
didn't want to have to simulate it no so
he scan me and using a Kinect to make a
3d model and then uh just a basic rag
dolls that are built into 3ds max when
it comes to the physics you can't tell
like you can't tell a program like I
want to I want to hit the basketball
hoop I want to be in a slam dunk
position when I hit the basketball hoop
physics don't work that way you set your
initial state and you hit simulate and
so I don't know catapult that would
launch my character so I launched it
once and it went too high and went to
the left so I screwed myself right and
slide it down it launched again I went
too slow and that over and over until it
just haven't hit the right motion just
have I gotta climb to the basketball who
can go fine and for the basketball hoop
actually moving like that we recorded a
plate
I had actually like jumped up go grab
the hoop and I just pulled it down until
it fell over end up putting my finger
doing that too I didn't uh yeah it's
gonna be a skarner oh wow so that's an
actual real element and just composite
me out of it and have me go hitting it
and hopefully with the basketball goal
being actually real and Niko's cg stunt
double the combination of the two will
actually look a little bit more
convincing than just having it hit the
backboard and the backboard not actually
do anything yeah it's great to always
make some real life interaction ever
since for example frozen crossing one
the Jets fly by and that caused the
branch to shake and like shakes no off
it's always like get a little bit that
real life interaction it goes a long way
if you actually go back and look at all
those equations on that whiteboard
they're not totally relevant but they're
slightly relevant because maybe at least
the portal gun or aspects of you know
portal science yeah Rendon studied
physics in college so I have a
mechanical engineering degree you
decided to write out leaders on the
board
ten are sitting there like half an hour
waiting from the finish just like yeah
what are you doing that trust me this is
this is a real thing some people are
gonna appreciate this I mean as real as
you can get with you know hypothetical
science fiction stuff and one point
actually figured out the terminal
velocity of a basketball from the
underside of the bridge I figured out it
was about two times per second that
would be coming through so at a BPM of
about 120 to be like some food but we
ended up scratching that shot before we
started shooting so now we have Niko
flying instead so I figured
isn't it like hotter in seven miles an
hour for you moon it's only 207 it's 120
hundred Dave if you're like normally
splayed out if you're going to a dive
then it go up to like 180 I bet Oh
because wonder have made the portal some
cells real quick Ren ten-second forward
breakdown go action essentials lay out a
few five elements pre-comp that and then
throw on polar coordinates wrap it into
a circle and stretch it out into a
portal and then you have like some fire
going this way and some fire going on
the opposite way as well so I've got a
balloon a little bit of glow a little
touch of optical flares getting the
dirty lens back use that as a
displacement map source and get like
those little rips going in there looks
good alright thanks for watching guys
hope you like little insight and how we
do the effects or portal trick shots and
guys stay tuned for some more sweet
videos from our Channel and 2015 alright